have to go to Coachella and Palm Springs
though to have some fun there's a new
local music festival which starts
tomorrow at Ferguson's downtown yeah and
the show isn't just about music it's
about helping the less fortunate Candace
Charles joining us live at Ferguson's to
talk about the sun can Festival good
morning
good morning to good morning folks
that's the first stop on our tour of the
best music festivals in Vegas Sun can is
the spot to be this Saturday here at
downtown Ferguson I talked to some of
the young minds behind it check out what
they had to say
just one big event meant to just bring
together the music and art community as
well as people who are music lovers if
that's you grab a can of food or two and
head to Ferguson Saturday you'll see 10
of Las Vegas's biggest indie rock and
alternative bands we're very like 90s
influence I get a lot of inspiration
from like I said dramatic artists so it
could be like Fiona Apple or mitsky but
you can group two at the first suntan
Music Festival excuse and and music and
art for some odd reason is is kind of
stirring something up really special in
Vegas right now Sun can is put on by
black sheep's bookings Shawna Salazar
and Jimmy steppenak of Arlo who met
local bands like the doll heads and
seikos on the rising star stage at Life
is Beautiful two heads are better than
one and in this case it's a lot of heads
putting it all together and you can rock
your socks off while giving back the
Music Fest doubles as a canned food
drive there's over 6 in homeless slash a
lot of hungry people in this city that
need some help bands like elevated
undergrounds and pure sports are pulling
out all the stops to help you give back
while getting down you can expect us to
get a little too sweaty uh push people
around a little bit jump into the crowd
our guitarist is crazy likes to run on
stage I like to do flips pure Bliss just
soak up at the very first suncan Music
Fest we're on a bubble that's about to
pop
[Music]
yeah absolutely and it sounds like it's
going to be a good time folks all ages
Festival is tomorrow evening starting at
5 30 there will be more than 20 art
vendors tickets are just 15 10 with a
canned food item I Hope You Get Enough
music in the back that is Arlo they'll
be joining us at six o'clock with a
little sneak peek of the festival we
have more details on our website
8newsnow.com and this is the first in
our coverage of Music Festival season so
stick with us for all the fun this music
festival season you know we got you
covered for now live from Ferguson I'm
Candace Charles 8 News Now